المجندات الكردية
يفتشون النساء المحجبات
واحدة تلو الأخرى
بعد أن هربن آخر جيب لداعش في
حقائب سورية يتم تفتيشها.
تعرّف نفسها فقط على أنها أم
مريم والدة مريم التي وصفتها
للأوضاع في بلدة باروز
الكئيبة ، يتم
فصل الرجال عن بعضهم البعض في
انتظار استجوابهم من قبل ضباط
المخابرات الفرنسية والبريطانية والأمريكيين الكرد
للبحث عن أعضاء داعش
والمواطنين الأجانب الذين
يحاولون الهروب  من بين المدنيين
قبل بدء الهجوم على
آخر قطعة أرض
لداعش ، قال مسؤولو القوات الديمقراطية السورية إن
حوالي ألف وخمسمائة مدني
كانوا في
الداخل ، ومن الواضح أن المسؤولين قد
قللوا بشكل كبير من عدد
المدنيين في البلدة
خلال الأيام الثلاثة الماضية.  أكثر من
ألفي شخص
تركوا بارو في الواقع
وهناك  ربما لا يزال هناك الآلاف
داخل وتحت قصف جوي وبري كثيف على مدار الساعة
،
لا توجد صورة واضحة عن عدد
القتلى والجرحى من المدنيين.
عودة مهدي صلاح وعائلتها كانوا
يقيمون في مخيم للنازحين
داخل البلدة
تقول إنهم غادروا مع طلقات نارية تحلق
فوق رؤوسهم
بينما ينتظرون نقلهم بالشاحنات إلى
مخيم للنازحين شمال هنا
لا يوجد قصف هناك جوع
متعطش  في البؤس
[الموسيقى]
تصل الإمدادات لقد نفد الأطفال في ثوانٍ
يتدافع الأطفال في الغبار القصاصات
ثم التقينا بسيينا في سهول
شرق سوريا